now comedians of all stripes have been
speaking out today in defense of the
controversial comic jerry sadowicz his
act was cancelled by the pleasants in
edinburgh the weekend after the first
night of his two-night run the venue
said his material did not align with
their values and that his views were not
acceptable in response service who's
known for his provocative stand-up shows
said his show had been cheapened and
simplified and in real life he didn't
want to offend or upset anyone well
let's speak now to the satirist
constantine kissing uh constantine
thanks for being with us you've been
writing about this today i know you feel
strongly about all this uh people will
be wondering what did jerry servants say
we're not going to go into that in any
specifics because some of the words
themselves are too offensive for us to
broadcast but he argues as we've said
context is everything this was part of a
much broader act let me ask you this is
it ever okay to use overtly racist
misogynistic homophobic language in a
comedy act
well you said it yourself in in the
introduction that it's all about the
context and i'm afraid there's a very
large number of people commenting on
this story who haven't seen jerry
sadowitz i haven't seen his show and
it's a very interesting thing that seems
to be applied only and exclusively to
comedy like if you go to watch macbeth
with your family you don't come back
going oh i saw a play and then this guy
went mental and stabbed his friend you
go it's a performance it's a theatrical
performance and the character of macbeth
and all the other characters in that
piece uh
characters theatrical characters in
exactly the same way that jerry
sadowetz's act is a comedic character
and so what a character may do is
completely different yeah but listen i
mean i've seen jerry sadowitz live in
the last couple of years i went to see
him myself he is very offensive he is
very challenging but he's not an obvious
character it's not like steve coogan
playing alan partridge he comes on and
me and maintains this act as he has done
right through his entire career it's not
obvious necessarily what he's doing and
how he's doing it but let me ask you
again
well necessarily to everybody in the
audience but let me just go back to my
first question is it ever okay then to
use overtly racist sexist homophobic
language in a comedy show well as i
explained if there is a character that
is doing a performance then they may be
able to do things that a person
expressing their opinions may not this
is one of the problems with what the
pleasants has done in this case instead
of saying we don't like his material
what they actually said if you go and
read the statement is we do not agree
with some of the opinions jerry sadowitz
expressed as if a comedy character is
the same as a person's opinions and this
is the problem we seem to have forgotten
that uh yes some words are very
offensive but it he didn't say them on
the bbc uh one scotland show he said
them in the context of a very specific
comedy performance i strongly by the way
disagree with you that it's not obvious
uh that this is a character reminder
this is a man who uh exposes himself on
stage as part of his act uh and has been
doing this for a very long time going to
a jerry sadowitz show and being offended
is like a vegan going to a steak
restaurant and being horrified that
there's dead animals on the table
it's ridiculous so what we have here
essentially is a venue censoring an act
does that concern you as an industry
we're already hearing reports tonight
that a venue in dundee is now
considering a gig that he's supposed to
be doing there
well it's not it's not something that
concerns me i've been talking and
writing about this for many years now uh
the comedy industry is going to be
destroyed by this process because what
will happen is people like me and many
others who want to do challenging things
and push the boundaries they're going to
go online and then you're not going to
have the stand-ups tour in the country
in anything like the same way it would
also mean over time the dead and the
festival becomes less appealing and
fewer people will come and perform there
and fewer people come and watch shows
there you we have seen only in recent
years uh the cancellation of the match
report the cancellation of mock the week
i i'm told that live at the apollo is
next this culture of censorship and
restriction is destroying comedy and it
will destroy the tv comedy that many
millions of people have been enjoying
for years as it already has done with
other shows and this process will
continue yeah just speaking from a
personal experience as i said i went to
see him a couple of years ago and
concerning one thing that i found
actually quite troubling that night was
i sensed that quite a lot of people in
the audience were there so they could
laugh at a bit of racism because they
don't get the chance all that often does
that trouble you
if i were a mind reader like you would
trouble me i have no idea why the people
were enjoying his show
i have more faith than human beings than
perhaps you do i believe that people
able to understand irony and uh
very clever comedy that jerry sadwords
does well as you as you correctly point
out i was there you weren't i was
watching what was going on around me and
trying to assess uh who thought what
about it but listen it was fascinating
did you assess that sorry well just by
judging listen to but by watching people
watching their body language and
listening to them around you you can
tell what someone's thinking no i'm not
i'm i'm not saying i knew what they were
thinking i'm just saying it struck me
that that might not you did say you knew
what they were thinking
it's been fascinating to hear your
opinions this evening constantine thank
you very much indeed thank you for being
with us this evening